alors là nos ou le cercle de montréal
anie samson luc ferrandez bonsoir
pourquoi bon ami je commence avec vous
est ce que c'est une brillante on le
veut brillant lan ou est ce une
brillante idée où j'avais des doutes
mais lorsque j'ai vu la nouvelle j'avais
certains doutes mais après ça je me suis
convaincu que c'était un beau projet
pour montréal et enfin un projet
exemplaire d'un gros projets qui vont
attirer les touristes ça met fin à tout
ce qu'on a vécu depuis les deux
dernières années avec la copine je pense
que c'est un vent de renouveau printemps
vous amène à se permettre de rêver un
peu plus loin puis devoir de voir
l'avenir d'un bon pied vient juste un
point où j'ai un peu titillé c'est
lorsqu'on on donne comme explication que
c'est beau permettent aux travailleurs
de venir travailler au centre ville je
postule mais ça va permettre aux
touristes de venir à montréal par contre
mes listes moi je pense que c'est une
idée géniale
et puis ce qui ressort de ce projet
lourd surtout c'est notre fierté
montréalaise et québécoise sait faire à
trois rivières celles conçues par des
québécois ça vient de chez nous c'est un
produit de chez nous qui va faire le
tour du monde ça pour moi je trouve
sincèrement qu'ils jugent qu'en pensez
vous d'abord je me suis aussi je suis
vraiment content d'en ça va être le plus
bel endroit de montréal on a la place de
marie conçue par paix il faut de grands
architectes internationale la place elle
même ou si content super content par
comme un autre grand aménagistes après
sur la place mais gilbert extraordinaire
j'ai pas si vous avez vu des plans qui
s'en viennent après sur l'université
mcgill une université à quelqu'un plus
formidable vert et or vient coller sur
le centre-ville depuis le mont royal on
peut pas avoir un axe de bouter plus
grand que ça c'est impossible même dans
les grandes villes du monde faisait ses
classes mondiales y là c'est un cadeau
aussi qui est fait par ivanhoé cambridge
aussi par la chambre de commerce etc
mais c'est pas le seul cas nous le leur
rétablissement des escaliers ça déjà
donné beaucoup de monde à cet endroit là
ça libère en train de se redéfinir le
cap de coeur moderne ça libère cette
perspective là parce que tout était
bloqué demandez vous n'avez plus besoin
l'on peut on du mont royal
jusqu'au centre-ville on y aille en
perspective il dit absolument absolument
et puis il faut dire quelque chose que
monsieur qu'hormis a beaucoup d'humour
et dans toutes ses installations il ya
toujours un peu d'humour lazy tout écart
et j'ai mis un euro oui si ça fait
valoir la boutique de la place parce que
même le reine élizabeth on trouve être
élégante été construit parce que c'est
car israël est d'un peu trop sobre
peut-être même et maintenant on en
trouve on y trouve la boutique quand
même cormier services ou produits fait
tout le temps ça il faut y mettre
l'humour et à l'illiade et trochowski
amis au palais des congrès qui sont
visibles de la rue il y avait ça à
toronto avec la fontaine avec les chiens
et a fait ça au square dominion avec la
demie fontaine couper les passerelles
c'est un gars qui amène de l'humour dans
la ville bon annie vous avez peut-être
lu défilé sur facebook ailleurs et des
gens là qui est qui qui déchirent leur
chemise presque exister frayeur puis
pourquoi mais de l'argent là-dedans pied
ça sera répit leur on est ce que
montréal avait besoin de ça vous
répondez quoi tout ça moi je dis que
montréal un institut international de
ville internationale
elle se doit de rêver d'avoir des
projets différents les projets qui sont
beaux des projets qui nous amène à
réfléchir mais des projets qui vont
attirer les gens moi tu es là où je suis
je suis dans une ville où il ya de l'art
un peu partout dans permanent et c'est
ce qui attire c'est ce qui donne la
beauté je comprends que les gens disent
ok pourquoi investir dans l'or on peut
critiquer leur mais on peut aimer on
peut le poids aimé mais l'heure est à
voir tout le monde est dans une ville ça
nous permet de voir les choses
différemment lorsqu'on visite une ville
qu'est ce qu'on va visiter ou revisiter
ses statuts ont revisité encore les les
grands glee les grandes oeuvres d'art
qui sont un peu partout et dans le
centre-ville le fait d'avoir le cercle
aussi on regarde on a une vision
directement jusqu en haut de la montée
en commun comme un monocle comme un dunk
ou encore mission réussie pour que l'udc
quelques secondes ou si il n'y a pas de
ya pas de wii mail vous êtes à tous
genres de ventes répétées oui mais c'est
pas le guerroué h de saint louis c'est
pas la tour eiffel c'est pas là bim de
chicago ne s'est pas du même ordre c'est
quelque chose que tu t es fini mans et
finalement infiniment mon achat mais la
particularité de montréal c'est le cumul
il y appelait est de plus en plus
d'oeuvres d'art intéressant moderne
significative un peu partout en ville de
voilà merci à vous deux c'est très clair
au fond si votre opinion votre analyse
merci